hey everyone I'm a teacher welcome to
Abby's kitchen today we're gonna do
things a little bit differently in my
what I eat in a day youtuber review and
I'm going to review myself yes this was
actually something that a lot of people
have requested and I thought it was a
really good idea actually because I
definitely have changed the way I eat
since then so this video was taken right
before I was gonna get married it's
essentially my pre-wedding diet so to
speak and I think it's really funny now
looking back three years later because
things have definitely changed so let's
take a look it's just a little bit
stressed but this is a good stress
reliever so there is no skipping
workouts at this point in the game and
and again I get you gotta get going so
I'm gonna go make a little coffee after
this brush my teeth and so first of all
music hasn't changed in three years
haha maybe we should do something about
that but the coffee definitely has I
cold brew nothing really to see here
it's just coffee almond milk whatever I
don't really love cold brew any more I
find it upsets my stomach so I'm more of
an espresso girl now but I guess it was
working for me then and it was really
easy for me to kind of grab and go and
take to the gym
I remember when I liked spinning things
have definitely changed so I'll catch
you and I'm really hot ready hey guys so
I just got out of my spin class this is
what a badass work it looks like really
red
really sweaty I'm exhausted but I feel
great and I'm so ready for a little
post-workout snack so come back to my
kitchen and I'm gonna show you what a
good eat so I I'm not like I don't think
I can smoothies I honestly haven't made
a smoothie of protein powder in a really
really long time I actually cut out any
protein powders and artificial
sweeteners or things that have
artificial sweeteners in them when I got
pregnant a few years ago just because
they're not really well regulated so a
lot of the times doctors and experts
don't recommend them for women who are
pregnant and since then I honestly just
kind of like guess I forgot about the
protein powder in my pantry it's just
been kind of like sitting there for a
really long time probably should get rid
of that but I just haven't really felt
the need to use it I've just kind of
been focusing on Whole Foods and whole
sources of protein like eggs and and
yogurt and and and other things like
that having said that I do really like
sour cherries after workout there was a
reason for that research has found that
sour cherries can help with muscle
soreness after a really good workout and
I like sour things so anytime I see sour
cherries in the freezer aisle at the
grocery store I do try to pick them up
they are delicious but yeah just not
really like into the smoothie thing
right now also I mean one thing I will
say about the smoothie is it's so fast
and convenient and a great thing to just
kind of grab and go after the workout I
was really paying attention to my pre
and post workout nutrition when I was
about to get married and it definitely
does help to have a source of protein
pair with a source of carbohydrates
about 30 minutes after your workout you
want to aim for that 20 to 30 gram
protein mark that's the kind of ideal
scenario because that's going to help
elissa an insulin response which will
drive the protein into the muscles to
get them refueled after that hard
workout so that is why I think smoothies
are really popular after a workout it's
just something that you can have that's
really easy and accessible that you can
quickly get into your system but I guess
I just kind of got bored of them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so I know that looks like really really
weird but I think I learned it from my
trainer and I've seen lots of people at
the gym do this basically just like a
really efficient way to bulk up your
oats and adding in some protein so you
kind of get that that protein
combination with the carbohydrates but
I've since figured out a way better way
to do this rather than cooking them
separately and then adding them together
which is a little bit strange and also
dirties to pots or pans I make something
that we call pros and I've got a whole
video in my on my channel for protes and
I also have some my favorite prout
combinations right here in my book the
mindful Glo cookbook but basically what
I do is I wit the egg whites until they
get really really fluffy almost like a
meringue and then I whip them into the
oats so that you end up with this like
really light airy fluffy bowl of oatmeal
that's packed with protein now I have
nothing against egg yolks
I love egg yolks and I actually save
them and nowadays what I do is I I cook
them in my son loves egg yolks I also am
a big fan of a runny yolk but they don't
really work in this kind of recipe
because they make them too savory and
they don't give it that kind of Airy
fluffy feel the same way we wouldn't add
egg yolks to like a meringue so it's
just kind of a recipe thing but I'm
definitely all 4 egg yolks do not waste
your egg yolks and now I eat a lot of
eggs from my hubby's farm so we have the
best eggs and the best beautiful orange
yolks
now I actually still do make protes
sometimes but I usually add some hemp
arts or some nut butter in there for
some healthy fats just to bulk it up a
little bit more and make it a little bit
more satiating
so I just finished up my weight training
session with my trainer I try to see him
about three times a week on the same
days that I do my spinning on my cardio
so I'm not doubling up on the weights
and I'm starving right now so I'm gonna
go make myself a little something
further I love that I was able to
workout twice in one day who has time
for that definitely not a woman who has
a child that's for sure
but that was the joys of having very few
responsibilities in my life I guess but
yeah I try to work out most days now at
least kind of get in some activity
whether it's going for a walk with my
son or going to the gym or kind of doing
some some time on the treadmill or
whatever but just I do feel so much
better when I move but I definitely do
not have time to go to a spin class in
the morning and then do another workout
midday not happening anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have like a mountain of vegetables I'm
gonna totally make fun of myself right
now because that's a lot of vegetables I
don't know how I fit that many
vegetables in my belly honestly and
today I still eat a lot of vegetables
I'm a big fan of getting near five to
ten a day at ladies and gentleman but if
I were to kind of redo that meal I
probably would cut back on the amount of
vegetables or like split that into two
meals maybe and then pair it with some
kind of you know whole grain like like a
quinoa or brown rice or whole grain
noodles or a starched like sweet potato
I think I would feel so much more
satisfied and not feel the need to enjoy
this like huge huge huge portion
vegetables it's like like a platter that
should be for a family that I consumed
all on my own
so that also I'm impressed that I like
made like cooked myself a lunch meal I
know I was like big on that back in the
day before about the hood but now of
course I usually just like pick up a
salad or have leftovers or for recipe
testing that day I'll just like eat
whatever we've made so there really
isn't such strategy and planning going
into my lunches necessarily which is for
better or worse but yeah I just
realistically don't have time for that
anymore
to set up for another one so this is all
the time I need a quick little bit of
energy a nice little snack to get me
through the next few few recipes so I'm
going to get to that right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
again tans have been a change in folks I
like never eat low-fat or fat-free
yogurt anymore even Greek yogurt which
is really high in protein which I love
just I find the full fat yogurt so much
more satiating and it's not as sour so
you don't need to add the kind of
sweetness from like fruit yogurt or
sugar or anything like that I also like
totally forgot about that high protein
cereal I think a brand sent that to me
is this like most of the random things
that I end up eating so yeah that was
probably just like something I had
randomly that day it's definitely not
like a regular part of my diet and I
haven't even seen that in the past like
few years but if I were to like have a
snack like that today I probably would
have like full fat plain Greek yogurt
for the protein and the fats some
berries on top a little crushed nuts or
hemp hearts or some kind of seeds action
and that would just be so much more
satisfying I also I love cereal love
cereal any kind of cereal but yeah I'll
occasionally have like a bowl of just
straight-up cereal with my son for
breakfast sometimes yeah we're just
cleaning everything up and getting all
the food put away but I need a little
quick something something to get me
through the rest of this cleanup so I'm
gonna go make myself a quick little
snack
I that's really unflattering shot right
there of the the celery fibers shooting
out of my mouth but in all honesty still
up on and better still love putting it
on everything in my oats and on my toast
and vegetables whatever and celery is
great - it's great crunchy little snack
do I want to pay $20 for an overpriced
glass of celery juice no I would way
rather to my food and it's a great
vessel for those healthy fats fiber and
protein that is found in not better so
can't complain about that so I'm gonna
make my little meal here and I'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that like zucchini little Bolognese
situation seems like something like
super lazy that I would probably would
do today and if you're gonna make
zucchini noodles you've got to really do
it my way I've got a whole video on how
to nail this and master this right here
but yeah I still don't eat like a lot of
carbs at dinnertime usually it's not a
hard and fast rule sometimes I have like
just a big bowl of pasta nothing else or
a big pizza nothing else because
sometimes that's what I feel like but I
just noticed from a sleep perspective
and a digestion perspective that I feel
my best eating more fats and protein at
bedtime and having more carbs earlier on
in the day when I'm buzzing about or
working out or whatever but yeah
sometimes I listen to those signals and
and my body's telling me and sometimes
I'm like that pizza looks awesome I'm
just gonna have that and that is totally
okay too
so whether or not I like listen really
intently I don't judge myself for those
food choices I don't make a fuss over it
I just kind of put that to bed and I
move on eat quick snack and I'll get it
really enjoy
I like totally forgot about baby bells
baby bells are the best and I'm gonna
definitely go out this week and buy baby
bells because I think baby II would love
them so that's going on my shopping list
hey guys so I'm just getting ready to
finish up my last snack of the night
this is a little cottage cheese with
tons of almonds on top as we toasted
coconut such a great snack it is loaded
with TC yes I'm gonna finish what a be
over there had to say yeah gosh uses a
great before us bad snack I totally kind
of forgot about it
but it's because it's loaded with that
casein protein which is a slow digesting
protein so it keeps you full and
satisfied all night and you don't wake
up hungry in the middle of the night
which I hate
so yeah I got for a lap back in rotation
it's a good snack having said that
nowadays usually smite time snack I go
for something a little more fun like an
ice cream bar or like a homemade muffin
or popcorn I love popcorn I'm kind of
obsessed with popcorn right now it's
probably my my favorite snack so if
there's popcorn in the house and there
is right now I'm probably having popcorn
as a bedtime snack but you know cause
she's is great I can't criticize myself
for that so good choice Abbi
mmm love it alrighty folks well let's
bring up the macro something that I
definitely don't look at it anymore but
I'm gonna gonna pull these up for you
guys so I calculated that I can seat
about 2300 calories the carbohydrates is
about 33 percent fat at 37 and protein
at 35 percent that was my daily calories
okay so that's like a normal amount of
calories for someone who's who's being
active as I was two times a day working
out some days and from a macronutrient
distribution I'd say that constitutes
like a low carb higher protein high fat
diet definitely way less carbs than what
I consume today I would say and so even
though I was you know I had a goal for
my wedding and I was eating in a way
that made me feel great I definitely
think I was being tempted
wellness and Diet culture in a way that
was not good for my mental well-being
diets don't necessarily need to be about
weight loss they don't need to be making
you feel hungry
to be problematic and even though I
wasn't going hungry I was probably very
satisfied and very full I was eating a
lot of food as you can see that
restrictive mindset is not healthy
because it's just not intuitive it's not
about trusting our body so yeah that was
three years ago and I've definitely come
a long way in my relationship with food
definitely enough to know and recognize
this kind of clean eating movement as
just another alias for diet and the fact
that you don't need to be going hungry
to be dieting in a sense to me to be
succumbing to diet culture and that's
ultimately what this was about you know
following meal plans weather or you know
following a specific way of eating
whether that's veganism or keto or you
know paleo or whatever you might feel
like you're eating enough food but it's
just simply not necessarily intuitive
when you're having to constantly think
through every single thing you put in
your mouth so I I definitely see that
now as you know someone who's come a
really long way in this journey and not
like that's not an overnight fix that's
not like a like a 30-day program that's
something you need to commit to in your
life every single day but I I would
really you know urge people to try to to
try to find it within themselves to just
love themselves unconditionally however
they may be you know I have a lot of
empathy and understanding for myself
back then three years ago as I was about
to walk down the island for so many
other women out there who are about to
take that step because there's so much
pressure on us women to look a certain
way on this very special day its
position as the most important day of
your life there's a million photos that
are we going to be taken of you you're
going to be scrutinized as you walk down
that aisle by every single person that
you know not only at your wedding but
also has access to photos and video
content alive
stream online so yeah I think that that
is definitely part of the problem beauty
standards in general but also specific
to women and definitely specific to the
cone kind of wedding experience and
wedding culture I definitely was
susceptible to kind of pulled into that
whole world and that promise and you
know wedding magazines and and wedding
websites the whole industry is totally
[ __ ] but if I were to go back today
and redo it all and and to kind of give
myself advice I would say Abbi you know
choose a dress that makes you feel
beautiful exactly how you are where you
don't need to worry about if you ate
something that's a little makes you a
little bit bloated or if you get your
period before the wedding and you don't
feel like a hundred percent or you know
just just choose something that you're
going to feel like a superstar in no
matter your shape or size and yeah that
would be my recommendation to other
women as well basically where I'm at now
where my body is not like where like I'm
not like I don't feel super comfortable
like this is the body that I that I I
don't know how to describe it but like I
don't look in the mirror every day and
say oh my god I have a rock and body and
especially now that like I've gone
through pregnancy I've gone through
breastfeeding I've gone through a [ __ ]
ton of hormones but like I
wholeheartedly and like I'm not really
happy with where I am at and that's like
that's enough for me okay so let's talk
about what I like about this video
number one is lots of good variety I
don't cut out any specific food groups
I've got dairy I've got protein I've got
you know your your brains in there I've
got fruits and vegetables all the things
are represented okay number two these
recipes are pretty accessible I mean all
these recipes are basically like throw
it in the pan and just like make
something happen which is really how I
like to cook nowadays as well it's just
so easy and simple and with the
exception of course of the protein
powder which i think is mostly like a
lot of people can find protein powder
now but I don't even use that really
anymore all the ingredients are things
that you probably already have in your
fridge
Pantry a basic grocery store you don't
need to go to any fancy health food
stores to get the that I put on my plate
that's for sure and finally lots of
antioxidants and fiber I got in tons of
veggies and fruit without going
overboard on the fruit which we see a
lot of here on YouTube so that's great
so based on the chronometer and my
analysis of micros I was getting a
little bit too much calcium and also too
much fiber like 52 grams not the end of
the world but if you're chronically
getting a ton of fiber it can cause
digestive distress so something to keep
in mind and because I was eating so many
fruits and vegetables I was definitely
getting adequate amounts of vitamins A C
and folate my vitamin D was apparently a
little bit low that day however most
people are not getting enough vitamin D
from food alone and and that's totally
normal and that's why I always recommend
people take a vitamin D supplement which
I definitely was that I didn't mention
it in the video so that Audi bad bad bad
ABI and it's you know I just think it's
really important that us youtubers call
out when we're taking supplements and
what elements were taking just so that
we're being transparent in everyone can
get kind of a full picture
so I'm telling you now because I that
went up three years ago okay so now
let's talk about the things that I don't
like so much and definitely things that
have changed since then
number one as we've already talked about
the restrictive nature of my pre-wedding
diet I definitely think there was kind
of this overwhelming diet culture
radiating through the video even though
I wasn't on a quote/unquote weight loss
diet it was still a restrictive non
intuitive way of eating that I've really
really tried to shed since then
number two so many vegetables again love
vegetables don't want people to think
that the dietitian is saying don't eat
your vegetables eat your vegetables but
I would say that there's just so much
fiber and and veggies going on here I
already talked about clearly I was
consuming a lot of fiber an excess of
fiber and so many vegetables can of
course cause digestive distress even if
they're cooked so it's good that
both of them were we're not raw but I
think if I were to just kind of cut back
on that and add some kind of whole-grain
like quinoa or brown rice or or
whole-grain pasta I would have felt so
much more satisfied and not need to
consume an entire farmers market of
veggies so one thing I like to do now
for example with nine zucchini noodles
is I do have Cikini noodles and half
whole-grain pasta so I'm getting the
satisfying element and also the fiber
from the and the antioxidants from the
veggies but I'm not overdoing it next I
definitely eat more plant-based protein
now I don't haven't cut out animal
products that's for sure I usually have
at least one meal or snack a day with
like eggs chicken or fish but nowadays I
definitely try to incorporate more beans
and lentils and legumes into my day
sometimes I kind of do a little bit of
both so I do a much smaller portion of
my animal protein supplemented by you
know beans or pulses or legumes and that
also helps to cut back on cost as well
I call it condom meat so you guys can
steal that for me and use it condom me
like condiment the meat should be a
condiment like a just on the side really
guys condom meat like condiment like a
like a ketchup okay we'll just cut the
condom and finally I batch prep a lot
more I don't have time to make myself a
beautiful meal for one in the middle of
the day I barely have more than 20
minutes to put together a meal while my
kid is begging to be picked up without
him throwing all the contents of the
Tupperware container drawer onto the
floor literally that happens every
single night so nowadays I do a lot of
batch prepping on the weekend I use my
slow cooker my inst pot I make freezer
meals and then I kind of just like
assemble the components during the week
so I make a lot of stir fries and and
it's just so much easier and when it's
not easy for me I'm really lucky that I
have the privilege that I just kind of
will order something and I her eats it
because for me it's just so much more
important that we sit down as a
family that is that I'm worrying about
how many grams of fiber is in my dinner
so that's kind of how I roll I just
don't really worry too much about it
I try my best to put a balanced meal on
the table as many nights a week as I can
and sometimes it's just a hodgepodge and
that's okay too so guys I think that
means I'm gonna have to do another what
I eat in a day video at some point and
the reality is with my Whataya dates is
that every day is gonna be so different
it's not gonna be a very good indicator
of my diet because there is no really
such thing but I'm probably gonna have
to do it anyway at some point so until
then I would love to know aside from me
who do you want B to review what diets
out there are interesting to you that
you're seeing on YouTube that you'd like
to see a dieticians perspective on I'd
love to hear your comments leave me one
below give this video the big thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and share with
your friends and I will see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]